but before we start let me ask you guys
a question does this guy look like
Connor this is what a Muslim person
looks like if you haven't met one before
it's 2018 we call it hijama
it's something that is highly
recommended I said I'm on a comb how are
you guys doing greetings of peace that's
what it means we even had our friend
Connor McGregor giving the salams I've
had you some of you guys request me to
comment on some of the interactions
between Habib and Connor and I thought
I'd do that but before we start let me
ask you guys a question does this guy
look like Connor this is what a Muslim
person looks like if you haven't met one
before
it's 2018 again does this Irish man
Crimea ever again
doesn't this brother doesn't he look
like Conor McGregor is that just me
nobody confuses me for a Muslim they
just never ask but what I do at home
that's my business and that's what makes
you a Muslim you have your religion out
of mine wanted to point out something
that I found first and foremost very
interesting as it is a practice that I
myself have incorporated into my life
and now we see Conor McGregor who one
might ask is he trying to get an edge
like Habib who's been actually doing
this what we call hijama
for quite some time I believe but
recently there's been some pictures of
Conor doing what is also known as
cupping we call it hijama
it's something that is highly
recommended by the last and final
messenger sent to mankind Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
it's something that has tremendous
health benefits it's something that I've
also done a live session on my
self and there'll be a link in the
description where I'll take you guys
from the beginning to the end of a
complete session of the hijama
and we'll also get some of the health
benefits from it from the professional
who does it with a medical doctor
commenting at the end and I found that
very interesting we got some pictures of
Habib doing the hijama
and then one might ask is Connor because
obviously he's studying Habib's life
right now he's trying to get into the
mind of Habib he's looking at his
lifestyles and he seemed like he picked
up a good practice the hijama but I'm
gonna tell you something even better
that he can get the edge on and he
should pick up on now the first thing I
want to comment on is the peace be with
you you know one over one point seven
billion human beings around the world
Muslims and Muslim is simply one who has
chosen freely to submit his or her will
to the creator of the heavens and earth
of the universe and it was interesting
to hear Conor McGregor saying that
salams now was he expressing that in a
thoughtful kind way or was he mocking
Habib I'll let you guys be the judge but
I believe that when anyone knows the
meaning of certain words it really helps
them to appreciate them much more and
when you know what a Salaam Aleichem
means and that it is also connected to
who Christians love and adore Jesus he
also greeted his followers at his time
he didn't say hey what's up guys
he would say peace be with you
assalamualaikum Shelia Malik Moses
Abraham and every messenger that the
Creator sent they all greeted their
followers with this greeting of peace so
next time you hear Muslims say
salaam-o-alaikum you can appreciate that
even more now in that next clip you see
Conner offering Habib
who's a Muslim some whiskey now it's
interesting to note that he also called
him backwards because he refused to take
the alcohol actually Habib is moving
quite forward and clearly according to
the latest scientific developments Habib
is moving forward not because of these
scientific developments but these
developments show that not even any
amount of alcohol is good for a human
being if you're a drinker we hate to be
the ones to break some sobering news to
you but a major new study says no amount
of alcohol is good for your overall
health
not even that cheeky glass of red wine
you might be holding as we speak on
Friday evening a survey in The Lancet
medical journal says the overall risk of
liquor outweighs any known benefits it
says alcohol accounted for nearly one in
10 deaths in people between the ages of
15 and 49 that data was recorded in 2016
across all age groups alcohol was
associated with 2.8 million deaths that
here did you get that no amount of
alcohol according to science is good for
the human being that means not even in
moderation the previous studies that
were conducted where people get this
common mantra that they throw off like
one glass of wine is okay or a little
bit this was all based on studies funded
by the alcohol industry to go ahead and
catch more fish or get more people like
yourselves who are on the fence maybe
because those who are going to drink
they're gonna drink no matter what but
people now who are maybe more
health-conscious they cared for their
body for the health of their mind they
didn't want it to deteriorate
they they were more conscious of this
now they actually got on board because
of somebody studies but now like Habib
he's actually moving forward with the
times but it's interesting Heating
refused it because of these scientific
studies he refused it because this is a
command from the Creator now Connor also
we believe he's a Christian many people
don't know that in the Bible alcohol is
also prohibited so habib is more in line
with even the bible and definitely in
line with what is pleasing to his
creator by abstaining from alcohol and
we don't have to get into the wisdoms on
why it's been prohibited there's one
example from this scientific study of
all the tremendous health disasters that
are called not not to talk about all the
murders and rapes and and all of the the
detriment to society the broken homes
alcoholism and anyone who consumes
there's different levels of alcoholism
someone who's dependent on alcohol if
it's daily weekly a few days a week you
might be a lower-level alcoholic as
opposed to a higher local level of
alcoholic but alcoholics aren't happy
people they're not help they're not
happy people you cannot be happy in life
when you're destroying your life
drinking alcohol and at the end of the
day it's usually a dead end and they all
end up at the end if they don't get help
for this they end up destroying their
lives so this is one point of benefit
that people can take the discipline that
habib has one towards his creator and
the love that he has towards his creator
to abstain away from the things that are
prohibited alcohol being one of those
things and you can really respect that
now the Irish people and the Muslims
have a great history behind them and the
Irish are very loyal good people who
don't forget compassion and love that
was shown to them at one point in
history there was a famine called the
potato famine and at this point in
history you had starvation that was
being rampant diseases and the Muslim
ruler at that time step forward and sent
money and food and humanitarian aid to
help contribute to getting the Irish
people out of this crisis and into this
day the Irish are thankful and they have
not forgotten this great good that the
Muslims did towards their brothers in
humanity the Irish now it's very nice to
see this brother
I believe he's from Ireland and he's
Irish
someone who accepted Islam who kind of
looks like Conor McGregor it's amazing
because it shows how Islam transcends
nationalism nationality language colors
because it's a universal way of life
based on pure monotheism and it brings
purpose of life to the human being so
it's very nice to see this brother who
accepted Islam now in closing when we
see Conor praising and taking Jesus as a
God this is something when we usually
ask people to think and why they do
something which is not nor was it
sanctioned by Jesus himself we see often
repeated and done a blind imitation of
people following what their ancestors
did and this is a statement that is told
to us in the Quran when you ask a people
why do they
worship their ancestors why do they
worship human beings prophets or they do
some of the things that are prevalent in
their culture based on no evidence they
say we found our ancestors doing this so
then they blindly follow them even
though they were ignorant of the truth
and they also followed a blind culture
so this is something where Conor
McGregor he might be a great fighter but
his Irishman who accepted Islam that is
the definition of courage to be able to
go above and beyond what everyone in
your families doing copying people
blindly imitating the culture around you
scared to look into the truth Islam is
easy to understand but many people are
not courageous enough bold enough to
step up and to live it because that's
the real challenge that's what you need
real courage because you will be
persecuted possibly you will be made fun
of possibly people will ridicule you
possibly but this brother he had the
courage to do that and this is where
Conor McGregor and others can get the
edge because you'll be connected
directly to God you see as a Muslim we
love Jesus we love him as he should be
respected and loved as a mighty
messenger but why do we not worship Him
because he never ever in his entire life
claimed to be God or a literal son of
God not metaphorically we're all
children of God metaphorically but not
literally and son of God according to
the Jew this meant someone and in that
language meant someone who was pious
righteous close to God but not a literal
son of God then you'd have two gods the
one God and then Jesus is the Son of God
you have two gods and then a third God
and then you have the Trinity and
you have confusion but this is where you
get the edge where it's simple easy to
digest will you turn yourself humbly to
your Creator alone pure monotheism and
you do what Jesus did because Jesus he
fell on his face and he prayed to who
himself no he prayed to the one God and
we'll give you three more points to
think about along with the one that's
already mentioned that Jesus never ever
called people to worship himself as a
creator but he worshipped the Creator
you can find this also in the Lord's
Prayer another point is his companions
that knew him the best his companions
they were always with him his disciples
they never ever worshipped him nor when
he departed from this earthly life they
never went out and called people to
worship Him they continued the legacy of
calling people to worship the Creator
alone and not the creation and another
reason why a great proof you could find
this in the Bible in mark 13:32 we know
that god almighty is all-knowing of
everything and we asked our Christian
brethren our friends and we do this out
of the love sharing this information not
to try to put someone down we ask them
God is all-knowing they'll say yes God
knows everything he's not ignorant of
anything was Jesus all-knowing did Jesus
know everything because if he was God he
would have to know everything but when
he was asked according to the Bible when
is that day meaning the day of judgment
how did he respond jesus replied of that
day knows no man meaning nobody neither
the Sun nor the Angels nor anyone on
earth
knows about when the day of judgment is
coming nobody knows it except God
Almighty except the creator and Arabic
Allah and Aramaic ilaha so this would
disqualify him of being God and this is
a simple easy to understand verse and
why we don't take him as a god but we
love him as a messenger who was sent by
God and so many people are accepting
this because it makes sense as Abraham
was sent by God and Moses was sent by
God and Mohammed the last and final
messenger was sent by God Jesus was also
sent by God to call you to the purpose
of life to give you instructions how to
live life to warn you about the Hellfire
to give you glad tidings of paradise and
what you need to do to get to it and
avoiding the punishment of the Hellfire
so point number two was that his
disciples they never worshipped Jesus
nor called anyone to worship Him 3 and
will conclude his blessed mother Mary
Miriam there's a whole chapter named
after his Blessed Mother in the Koran
she carried Jesus for around nine months
was she worshiping Jesus when he was in
her belly
no she worship the one that Jesus
worshiped while he was in the bed belly
the crater the heavens and earth then
she gave birth to Jesus she didn't give
birth to God she gave birth to Jesus so
Mary the mother of Jesus she carried him
she breastfed him she fed him and then
when she continued on with her life she
didn't worship him nor did she call
others to worship him she worshiped the
one who created her and him and this
whole universe and everything in it so
this is where Conor McGregor can get a
edge like Habib has by connecting
directly to the one who created them who
created this universe and everything in
it and I want you to take a look
and the look-alike Conor McGregor our
brother
from Ireland take an example on how he's
praying
check out Habib what's he saying now
what's he doing he's praying to the
Creator why don't you do that if you're
a hobby fan and you want to get the edge
in life why don't you try doing what
Habib is doing I can tell you right now
what he's saying
in that prayer we say it 17 times a day
calling out to the Creator saying all
praises to Allah god all-mighty the most
merciful the compassionate master of the
Day of Judgment you alone we worship you
alone we seek for help guide us to the
straight path the path of those whom you
have favoured not those of those who
have earned your anger or have gone
astray so why don't you start out with
their prayer humble yourself look right
now how big how Habib is putting his
forehead humbling himself on the ground
and ask for direction and purpose in
life you can't go wrong but you can get
the edge from doing it hopefully
there'll be some benefit here thank you
very much like share hit the
notification button and we'll see you
here every week on the Deen show until
next time peace be with you
as-salaam alaikum are you guys doing
are you guys ready I'm ready for them to
start
there might be some muscle tension in
that ear
pajama you are giving a bad blood off
your bodies go to Waterloo small yeah